what is symbolism
well I think symbolism is a way
of making invisible things visible
that's uh a concept I guess that I
learned from observation of Alfred
Hitchcock's work because he uses a lot
of
things in the environment uh in a
symbolic way
sometimes it's an object that represents
some idea that he's trying to transmit
sometimes it's simply environmental
things like sounds or Shadows he will do
little things like if someone is trying
to decide if they're going to do
something or not if they're going to be
involved in a spy plot or something like
that he sometimes will sneak in a little
train noise on the soundtrack just a
little
like some the train is leaving are you
going to be on the train so he's giving
you subliminal messages
that you might think is it just random
sound but in fact it's totally
intentional and so uh it's his way of uh
bringing out this other dimension the
people are talking they're doing things
there's action but they're also feeling
things and there are forces
in the story uh that are almost
operating like gods or fairies sometimes
you get that feeling in Hitchcock's
movies that he himself is a puppeteer
manipulating things or that there is
some kind of
malign God who's looking out for these
people or
laughing at them
so the symbols help to convey those
things
uh but I think that's the key to it is
that symbols are a way of making
invisible
ideas feelings Concepts visible to the
audience
and uh
it's quite wonderful the way you can
just show me something like a glass of
water
and I'll start if you emphasize it in
the frame and just Linger on it for a
second I'll start thinking well what
does that mean is that what is that a
symbol of well the glass is half empty
so maybe this character is at that point
and they need to fill the glass or they
need to drink or the glass is maybe
going to break and you know it will mean
something in the text of the story and
we're so ready to do that
that it makes it quite easy for
filmmakers to assign these things and it
doesn't have to be even the thing it
could be a color or a sound
sometimes a good filmmaker will will use
a color to Signal you something bad is
going to happen or uh don't go there you
know that every time you see the the
color green perhaps something bad
happens and if after that sequence of
cause and effect happens two or three
times every time the audience sees green
they're going to be scared and they'll
they'll know on some deep level they'll
know that this is trouble coming
so this is one of the ways that that
symbols can be used and and the audience
uh enjoys playing with those toys you
know uh with imagining what is what does
that mean what does that symbolize
so it's almost like um pavlovian there's
a you they're starting to train you so
you salivate when you're the Bell kind
of thing it is it is like a Pavlov's dog
sort of response that uh we pick it up
very quickly that uh if you see an evil
character cooking uh you know that's
what he does just before he kills
somebody so after one or two examples of
that the next time you see him cooking
you're just waiting or who's gonna die
you're looking around for uh who is he
coming after next
so it is it is fairly easy to program
the audience with little cues like that
it's a lot of fun to find those things
you talk about the
embolism in myths and how symbols
communicate Universal truths
yes symbols in myths have their own
peculiar power
I think this started uh around what they
call attributes in you know the
scholarship of Greek gods and goddesses
every god and goddess has certain
objects or animals that are associated
with them and when we see that object or
that symbol
we might suspect that God is nearby or
that that the hero maybe is under the
influence of that god or goddess
Athena for example who's a goddess of
wisdom has a number of things that
are associated with her in art so when
you make a picture of her or a sculpture
or something
you include those things and it helps
tell the audience oh that's Athena but
because she has an owl on her shoulder
which is a symbol of wisdom she has a
certain
piece of armor on her chest that's
called the Aegis that protects her she
has a helmet pushed back on her head
that represents that she's a warrior
goddess and she sometimes has a spear
and so forth so all those things are
Clues to that character's presence or
that God's presence
but also can kind of move around
independently of them so when the owl
comes by you know Athena is watching out
uh this is a uh an idea that comes out
in Scandinavian mythology
that the god Odin uh has his own
attributes and tools and weapons and so
forth but one of the things he's
associated with is two Ravens who sit on
either side of his throne and they're
always going out and flying around and
gathering information and then they'll
come back and tell him what's going on
uh on Earth so when you see Ravens
circling around you know Odin is nearby
and they actually put this into the text
of the Vikings TV show the HBO series
that every time the Ravens show up you
know Odin is paying attention and the
hero has you know maybe access to that
at that point
so the these symbols help
to suggest what what is the energy at
that moment are we under some dark
dangerous influence uh or are is is some
God looking out for us
and sending their messenger in the form
of one of these animals or just an
object that represents them
sure and then with the the quote unquote
villain uh there was always fear of the
witch's familiars the cats or different
uh rats or sometimes even Raven suit
doing the evil bidding for the witch
when he or she wasn't there yeah you
know these animal uh familiars or animal
Sidekicks are very useful when I was
working for Disney we were developing
the movie that eventually became Aladdin
and uh this was very early in the
development Aladdin was uh kind of uh
immature Street kid
and he was a solo act he was like uh in
the original Top Gun kind of a guy who
didn't need anybody else was not a team
player and as it developed
he got a little more mature they had a
different idea of the ideal person to
play that more of a more like Tom Cruise
but uh I said in the sessions discussing
all this it would be so nice if the hero
had somebody to talk to or somebody who
could go with him on the adventures and
observe and comment and I said it could
be a camel or it could be a monkey or
something and the animators went monkey
and started drawing the hero's sidekick
a monkey and then I said well maybe the
villain needs one too
so they created this character Iago who
was this harsh voiced parrot who sat on
the villain's shoulder and the villain
was very serious but this other
character was the humor of the piece so
the monkey didn't talk he made noises
but he couldn't speak but he let he let
you know what he thought about things
and we kept going with this and I think
I and some other animators had the same
idea at the same moment which is well
he's got this Magic Carpet why can't we
animate that why shouldn't that be a
character with its own expressive
abilities and the animators went wow
that's great and immediately started
drawing pictures of the the rug uh
waving hello or shrugging or crossing
you know the two corners to cross its
arms disapproval uh you know they they
found this whole vocabulary for a piece
of carpet and and turned it into a
character who added Dimensions to the
story so uh I I've enjoyed uh you know
making that that contribution that isn't
in the original uh Source stories of
Aladdin or any of those Arabian Night
stories but uh you know that's that's my
little pleasure is to have planted some
of those things